[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
you
you
summer of chess comes to an end as 20
international grandmasters compete in
st. Louis u.s. chess champs calm
presents the third annual fall chess
classic hello and welcome to the 2019
fall chess classic my name is Caleb
Denby I'm joined by the wonderful
Grandmaster Denis Boros and we're going
to be covering the action today for the
fall chess classic and it's shaping up
to be quite an exciting tournament isn't
it this looks astounding and some heavy
heavy action there's already underway
yeah absolutely
why don't we take a look at the players
in this tournament here's the roster for
Group A in the first seat position is
front mokume ian from armenia the world
number 100 player directly following him
is Ray Robson with actually an identical
Feud a rating after that comes Alexander
epitaphs Darrow's routes alexander
Lenderman Massif dura Bali Jordan Vaughn
forest VAR a Cobian Alexander bortnik
and Ilyas Marin a star-studded field
with almost every player you know over
2600 actually receive 1 2018 one classic
yeah I believe he's the 2018 Summer
chess class champion so he's coming back
to st. Louis now trying to add more
seasons under his bounce yeah
and so we'll wish him luck with that and
now let's take a look at the B group of
players heading up the B group is Manuel
but Petrosyan also from Armenia
following him is Viktor Michalowski yes
sir Quezada Perez Denis Cade Rick Aram
cocoa bean Alexander fier Jack Jim bull
yak Steven Zurich Oman Hambleton and
abetik Gregorian a lot of st. Louis
veterans in this field here with am on
the chest broad coming back to st. Louis
some former Grand Master and Residences
even who you know shared your position
yes
in fact Jacksonville yak I remember
seeing can across the board playing a
playoff now yes for the van Winter
Classic was it no it was it was the norm
congressman on Congress yes so I still
remember playing him so it would be
exciting to commentate on his guy yes
and of course Jack was actually
victorious yeah in that in a thrilling
match well why don't we take a look at
the format for this tournament as we see
there the players all in the tournament
hall hard at work there are two ten
player round robins one in the a group
one in the B group and the time control
for this event is 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves and then they get thirty
minutes added on for the remainder of
game after move forty that slow include
a 30-second increment from move one and
interesting in this tournament much like
the Sinquefield cup there are some draw
rules in effect so players are not
allowed to offer each other a draw until
black makes his thirtieth move so no
draws except by repetition before the
move 30 as always you're welcome to join
us on social media here follow along
with the games on us chess champs calm
get involved on Twitter with the hashtag
fall chess classic and we are keeping an
eye on the YouTube chat if you have any
questions for us questions for the
players we're happy to answer some of
those with that of minds why don't we
just take a look at the pairings for
group a in round one olexander bortnik
was paired against Robson and that game
has actually already ended in a draw
yeah it was kind of tedious game yeah it
was a c3 Sicilian so you shouldn't be
surprised if it and then draw quickly
and nothing happens absolutely
hopefully we're going to have Ray come
by and talk more about the game and he's
yeah expectations for this event it'll
be interesting to hear his thoughts both
on this game and what he expects to
achieve up next was Alex epitaph against
fraud Malcolm Ian Alexander Linderman
paired against borrow Kobe and st. Louis
native Jordan van forest is paired
against and Aris routes and Vassy furor
bali is paired against Elias
miron in our key matchup of the day
these two players squaring off directly
in round one so let's take a look at
that game dentist and see what's going
on
so this shapes up to be a great game as
smearin who's famous for being a big
great fighter and he was 2,700 in his
heyday yes
so in all rights a legend and all-around
Israeli Olympian he always plays for the
Israeli team and I think we achieved
bronze or they did get a medal where the
team consisting of Galvan and smearin so
no wonder he went c5 here he's already
looking for some action
hoping for a Benoni but Wasif has other
plans and goes for the Knight f3 line
this was actually championed by
Carlson's longtime second Neilson Peter
Hina Nilsson and she loved playing these
type of structures where you actually
get a reversed Greenfeld positions so d5
you can't really take right now because
Queen takes and the rook will be under
attack so you're forced to play Bishop
g2 be five but now black gets the center
but but we'll get some counter play know
that you can't take on e5 because
there's this nasty little check the
classic for the classic for your old
dreaming of what never happens in our
games sadly so castles knight c6 e 3 and
this been very popular among their
minions yeah aronia also Carlsen
although he's Norwegian so Bishop e7
happened
he takes d4 a takes d4 and the old main
line is rook e1 Castle and Bishop f4 but
here there are badly came up with a very
enterprising move before Wow which is an
volte or at least I think there was
maximum two or three games played
recently and the point is that black is
just a half a move away from castling
but if you would Castle here would go b5
and I win this pawn on d4 and who
wouldn't want to be up upon 4 yeah
playing very very immediately with white
yeah rather than taking it a bit some
more slowly and I don't know just
challenging this pawn with something
like b3 or Bishop b2 right so you could
good play b3 m Bishop b2 but usually
that's kind of slow black would have
time to play Bishop c5 and sometimes
even d3 because this F 2 upon
surprisingly can become really weak
right so smearin as we know is a big
fighter so he didn't shy away from a
challenge and he took the pond yeah but
then came the shocking move Knight takes
d4 I'm shocked you should be so what's
the idea after Knight takes so I have
Knight X I have Queen a4 check
interesting so Knight takes Queen a4
check you should try to defend this
bishop the knight c6 takes you part with
that bishop but now you will stop this
came from castling and that's stuck
there forever
rather uncomfortable yes it's very
uncomfortable playing this and
especially in the near future Bishop a3
is coming so this is kind of nasty yeah
this is not not what I would want out of
the opening yes
so instead smearin decided to castle
rather sacrificing a bond and suffering
in a position where he has to defend
that's a bit more responsible yes it's a
responsible way of playing but it's
risky
something that's very close to smear in
style but the seif said okay I'll take
your pawn B takes Bishop b3 actually
decides to exchange of this active piece
verse
saying that this pawn will never run
away uh yeah that's a fair point
it's it's not as though black and try to
defend it with something like Bishop d7
or Bishop d7 because then that
LightSquared Bishop is just gonna be
passive yes so for example what caleb is
saying I'd guess this is what you're
talking about yeah any passive just like
rook d6 I have more pressure so yeah and
there's nothing black can really do
everything together I'm threatening to
go rook a d1 and probably in the long
term you should get crushed right at
this level so at this full chess classic
a group level you're gonna get crushed
in like 15 moves yeah definitely
this is now because in the future the
spawns just gonna be captured as Knights
see to 94 or 94 will come and this will
be just a mayhem so rugby 8 was played
so black decides to make a useful move
defending that Bishop on b4 and also
trying to win some time because as long
as this knight on b1 is stuck
it's very difficult to prove the
advantage yeah I would definitely agree
with that but at the same time how do
you get it develops I guess you have to
take this bishop and just develop blacks
rook well yes but you can wait with that
actually that's what received it took on
c6 Bishop h3 and after he got that extra
pawn decided okay I'm up upon Sun
willing to develop your rook to be 4
fair enough
it's Knight d2 and let's be honest here
black does have some compensation yeah I
would definitely agree it's tough for me
to see if White's really going to manage
to keep this C pawn at the moment it's
definitely going to come under fire so
definitely this King is kind of
uncomfortably placed yes as well if
you're familiar with the marshal and I'm
sure you are
yes so this is kind of a marshal type of
an game
they're White's weak King is often in
the way of getting the advantage so do i
Bailey is facing the same problem of
trying to convert an advantage when your
king is in constant danger yeah
not that you should get made it but if
you lose this lonely pawn on c4 you just
lose the advantage we were saying yes
you're slightly worse already right so
h5 was played it's the same idea kind of
putting some pressure on the King
bouquet b1 exchanges are always good if
you're up upon Ruby eight but the reason
is I guess why he didn't exchange
because it Ruby three you can't prepare
this rook maneuver and exchange even
more rooks
yeah and the closer white gets to a
minor piece ending is the better friend
yes the major pieces are very good at
attacking isolated pawns like the C pawn
and minor pieces on the other hands kind
of struggle to prevent them from pushing
forward yeah so Ruby six and now we're
waiting let me double check if moves
were played yes so Ruby six was played
attacking this Bishop and yeah
objectively I think white is much better
here
much better but smearin has good counter
play right so Bishop F three of us
played um interesting would you consider
going Bishop g2 Caleb bishop Shih Tzu
I'm not so sure that I would I think
that blacks Bishop is is you know
certainly hurting my my king but I think
my bishop is going to be very useful in
controlling the c6 square so if I can
play a move like c5 then I really want
my Bishop on the board to control c6
yeah I agree
like exchanging is good but cleaning is
better yes so that's why there are badly
played Bishop f3 and decided okay I
could exchange stuff but who knows if
I'm gonna win that yeah fair enough
so Bishop f3 buzz play it bouquet 4 and
C 5
and at them the bishops you really see
the usefulness yes now you can see X is
impossible that this rook is working
full-time and actually in the future I'm
not sure that we're going to care about
that pawn anymore right we can start
promoting that and we're not that far
off it's just three squares away from
promotion I can count to three
yeah I'm ready to do it so actually
let's see what if with a sexist plate
probably see six takes and see seven so
we actually caught up to the current
position then yes we made some moves so
where those where the pros that now the
players at c5 okay and Spearin is
thinking so the time is correct smearin
has twenty minutes and do our belly has
18 yeah not a lot of time to figure out
an angle and as complex as this yeah
definitely black very much on the back
foot here yes I wasn't able to prove
that compensation against that white
c-pawn and now I think he's in quite a
bit of serious danger yeah this looks
like make trouble for black even though
I think there's some hopes of survival
here yeah I definitely agree but let's
just take a look at the current position
how does black solve the immediate
problems to me it looks as though c6 and
c7 is coming along life force perhaps he
starts with Ricky six and a 56 Brooke e
7 but rookie 7 I can go over B 7 I think
yeah and if my pawn reaches the b7
square then protection by dis vicious I
think this is the end my friend the end
yeah but you got to play with the white
pieces there that's true what what does
black do is my question definitely I
would consider rook e8 instead okay but
again c7 and Ruby 8 this coming so this
looks very sketchy
this looks very sketchy for black I very
much do not like his position here so I
think smearin can still fight but
probably this is a big chance for
received or badly to win yeah I
definitely expect a full point from the
Seif here this is a very very difficult
position well so why don't we let those
players get back to it and we can take a
quick look at the pairings in Group B
should see how they are doing we have
Appa Tech Gregorian playing in Stevens
Erick yeah circus tada Perez playing as
Dennis Kade Rick jack Shambu lyac
playing against chess bruh Aman Hamilton
a rhombic Oh bein against Victor
Michalowski and Manuel Petrosyan playing
it's Alexander PA and there we see the
two players in the B group squaring off
in round one and they are also playing
quite the interesting game yeah
definitely the chances going on here as
well why don't we take a look at the
position let's take a look it's very
interesting game because fear is known
to be the most active player at some
moment right I think he played like 30
games at 30 not just 30 games 30
tournaments in a year wow that's a lot
of games and notably he beats vojta SEC
in the World Cup which is a huge result
and Salaam but his opponent is famous in
his own right he's actually the current
second of Levon Aronian
so he was helping out Levon at the
Sinquefield Cup and the chess960 LX so
definitely probably one of the most
informed players then yes I don't know a
lot about being a second but I imagine
it really keeps you up to date on your
openings things of that nature because
you have to be so prepared in order to
help those top players out so actually I
want to show a moment go back a few
moves mm-hmm
so this moment the position is still
very even and it's supposed to colored
bishops but this is the moment when it's
good to have
30 move rule right because by now we
could say Oh draw how about a draw now
yeah and but you know the player has had
to keep playing but they had to keep
playing and some interesting thing so my
play g5
so what Manila petrosyan is trying to do
is just too soft and this King size
structure it makes sense to me so fear
weighted rugby seven takes takes and
actually from personal experience this
can be very annoying for the defender to
know that there's a 30 move rule the
position is objectively drawn right but
you can't offer the draw so you don't
want to get too ambitious exactly you
don't want to get too passive so Brooke
a b7 was kind of like a waiting move
it's not really doing anything
mm-hm and probably it was time to do
something probably f5 which looks kind
of weird but there's no real weaknesses
left if f5 is played yeah no weaknesses
I might agree with that but the King can
also be a weakness this game can be
become a weakness but I can imagine why
playing something like Rickey 5 and then
trying to get this other rook to e3
yeah and trying to generate some
pressure that way so I mean I agree that
it's it's tough to really break you
there so it's probably and white can try
but probably after ISA Krug d5 it should
be around even ish just setting up on
the light yes like a white square
blockade of sorts but fear played rookie
b7 I'm kind of waiting and G takes f6
he takes f6 look at 4 and here fear
doesn't realizing that something bad is
about to come down
played rook d5 and I guess this is what
I'm really talking about is that you
reach you're trying to reach move 30
you're kind of certain that the position
should be very dead even right and you
should be getting there and then you
make a passive move then you make an
aggressive move
and suddenly you're dead lost Wow and
rugby five and this was a huge mistake
because of the best moves yes a 400 very
interesting yes so if you take and
that's what happened this is just a
tactical miss then I guess suddenly
there's a double attack here
and black is under huge pressure you
can't even move the bishop because the
c6 pawn is falling this pawn is just
falling and if that falls then the whole
position just collapses exactly the good
news for black is he's not going down
upon but I guess the bad news is his
King is going to be very very weak yeah
this f6 pontus yes so Bishop takes a for
bishops d3 happened and now this is the
double attack we've been talking about
Bishop d1 takes and sadly enough the
King cannot ever go to g7 because of
route d6 rook d5 and I take the d1
bishop let me show it to you guys here
takes takes and this fellow on d1 is
gonna get captured disaster yes disaster
was struck King g8 had to be played but
then King he won and this King e1 is
actually the move that should be praised
a lot of times when you're winning and
I'm kind of sure that Petrossian is
already winning here most of the times
people forget about safety first
interesting even though you're up like a
few pawns and probably you're gonna win
one more yeah I would have been very
tempted to take g6 your c6 yes go go go
go and collect but King g1 is a very
nice move getting rid of this bishop
that was kind of harassing the c2 pawn
right so Bishop b3 was played now he
took on g6 rook c5 Bishop d2 takes six
Ruby for Bishop g5 c5
and this king is already cut off spawn
is extremely weak and I'm not saying
that fear is like definitely gonna lose
this right but this is a connected pass
pawn and it opposes a colored endgame
yeah
and that there's a high chance of losing
yep black is technically only down one
pawn
yeah but with these connected passed
pawns kind of unopposed
and black C pawn not really posing a
threat it feels a lot more like two
pawns yes you know these pawns can work
together to maneuver up the board
controlling those key light squares that
the the dark dark squared bishop cannot
and so uh I I would think of the Sun
game is just winning yeah I would intend
to agree with you and also it's
interesting to point out the time the
Trojan has 34 minutes yes and fear has
one hour 17 minutes yes oh this is
assuming that I think this is I might be
onto something that 30 move thing right
and I might even be curious what
Petrosian will say was there like any
like okay this is a draw kind of gesture
from the opponent there's some
interesting psychology there yes it's
almost like you want to appear it like
of course this is a draw I don't yeah I
don't even have to try I'll just make
any move and then uh and then in the
game it just show up and chess is not an
easy game yes and I mean I would predict
that is a possibility
just by looking at fierce clock he must
have been like shuffling really fast
right and making quick moves saying that
okay this is a draw missing this a4 move
yeah and that's not a difficult tactic
to - well the easy one it's not the
easiest tactic but if you're taking your
time yeah if you're a player of this
life definitely that's yeah that you you
never miss I think mmm he wasn't alarmed
he felt that his position is safe
already
right yeah definitely just needed to be
a bit more on guard but why don't we
take a quick look at what these players
are playing for there are there is a
substantial
prize fund for both of these groups in
the a group they're playing for a total
of twenty-two thousand dollars with
first place taking home a cool 6k and
over in the B group they are playing for
a total prize fund of $14,000 first
place coming away with four thousand
dollars not a bad payday at all there we
see the the tournament hall and where do
you want to head to next Dennis the
world is your oyster we could possibly
take a look at the chest bra let's take
a look at that yes Brian I've got some
insider information on this game I had a
chance to briefly talk to a mod last
night I actually know he's feeling a bit
under the weather so it'll be Wow see if
that has impacted his game at all and
they received the two players in that
tournament home so let's start from the
beginning so c4 was played the big hype
these days yes very interesting English
English so yasser would be happy but I
have to emphasize this is yasser sara
vaughn who would be happy because we
have a yasser yá'át'ééh
Quezada playing yeah actually not uni
ASCII Yasser Quezada playing right and
that's interesting I'm not used to
having more than one users yeah it's not
the most common answer but we've got the
other grandmaster yeah say yeah in our
event so the other grandmaster are
yasser would be thrilled to see one c4
c5 Knight c3 Bishop b4 so the old main
line is Knight f6 g3 and d5 and we
actually seen this Bishop c5 idea being
played in the World Championship match
between cause them yeah Iran uh Bobby
just trying to state that you can just
play it like a Sicilian reverse yes
right this is how white would play if
the game is started efore c5
so this is a different type of game this
was handled in that World Championship
match
but Hambleton came up with Bishop b4
this is a trickier line it's not as
popular but it's gaining traction
Anand used to play this and had some
fine results 95 Bishop c5 III Knight f6
before and this might look strange for
the untrained eye but this is a typical
move of trying to gain some Tam P so you
can attack that a5 pawn and certainly
less strange than b4 in that other
position that was yes this is a bit more
typical yes
so Bishop e7 takes takes and Bishop b2
so if you would take this fawn I would
capture the central pawn and I would
claim that I have the bishop pair a
potential extra central pawn and I will
be happy it's a reasonable enough claim
so castles Knight f3 d6 now notice that
mr. Imam Hambleton is aiming to have a
close position he's not interested in
opening up the position at all right
because of that bishop pair advantage
yes that white has so he's trying to
build a wall so this Bishop cannot blast
through it yeah so that's why you didn't
see for example move like efore from
black yeah that would open that diagonal
for that bishop and while it gains some
central space it's definitely not worth
it to activate the white pieces yes and
d6 was played d3 Bishop g4 there should
be 2 a5 and actually I would love to
praise this move and I will because what
is a knight without an outpost well a
bad yes
so what Amon is trying to achieve here
is to create a nice little outpost on c5
and that actually happens because
stamboli AK allows it actually he could
have gone a3 which I actually would
prefer that would have been more natural
in my opinion I'm just keeping the
tension b5 was a little bit
No yeah you also see when accurate es
want to play the move c5 himself in
these characters right to try and break
down that the best of Evo's and you're
kind of giving away that option you have
to smooth b5 yeah so I think a three
would have been better just keeping the
tension because after b5 it gives free
play for block got h3 takes takes e4 and
now this is going to be an interesting
struggle between bishops and Knights I'm
interested who would you pick uh my
instinct says actually I would prefer
black here
despite that Bishop air advantage these
Knights are going to have some nice
squares that definitely the c5 square
and this light squared bishop mm-hmm
isn't looking very impressive to me yeah
I'm not sure where he intends to stay
for the rest this Bishop is probably
just going to stare at the knight very
soon
yeah deny just jumps to e4 mm-hmm the
other jumps to c5 and I agree with you
that black has a comfortable position
with those two nights yeah very natural
play it's a follow Luke a 890 c5 this
should be one f5 and actually it's funny
this position kind of reminds me of
Dutch Leningrad structures but it's like
an improved Dutch because you Dutch
Leningrad because you didn't play g6 nor
did you play c6 so you have no
weaknesses Wow yeah so this is the
current position yes so it's very
interesting to note the the clock
situation here yes I'm on down to just a
minute and a half and how many moves
left to play until move 40:21 that 80/20
has a minute and a half for 20 moves he
does get that 30-second increments on
every turn but definitely not where you
want to be sitting when you're dealing
with a head cold so what would be your
prediction for this game for this game
honestly I think it depends on the next
few moves for white here if white can
make a few solid moves improving moves
and not spend all of his time doing it
then I think he definitely is going to
have an edge just due to that clocks
based on position these Knights aren't
unassailable eventually I think we're
going to see white play this move f3 to
get rid of this knight on e4 and now you
can't do it until the time is absolutely
right but that's always something that
black is going to have to worry about
yeah because after f3 once this Knight
moves you see that LightSquared bishop
on b1 come to life attacking f5 and you
also see this knight on c5 become a bit
more loose threats of Bishop takes e5
might might even occur so a lot of
things for black to worry about is what
I'm saying and yeah with just a minute
and a half on the clock it's tough to
keep all of these things in mind yes
but I think all those Chesbro fans I
don't get sad Aman's a good blitz player
yeah no that horse and also he can
rebound if Y does not paying too much
attention and the rook would fling over
to e6 and g6 potentially the g2 pawn can
become a target so serious threats might
occur so there are some hidden counter
chances for Hamilton and I wouldn't be
surprised if he would launch a counter
attack and the winning one at that uh
yeah you can definitely see see that
happening as well and so really just
these these next few moves I think are
going to be absolutely getting you yes
what might happen if white were to play
f3 just immediately here mm-hmm
and three actually it's black to move so
no it should be white oh yeah okay so
new moves were playing okay so we saw
Luke c8 was played Rick see it preparing
this c6 so just to answer your question
if f3 was played then c6 and Papa to the
Queen disaster disaster fee struck as
the Queen has nowhere to go so this is
how how white is black is finding some
yes some immediate play then yes by the
way I heard that via waiting for ray
Robson to come
okay so hopefully we will get him in the
studio soon and so this Queen would be
terribly trapped
yeah not so good not so good for why so
probably either the bishop has to move
or either the bishop has to move back or
take on e4 which one would you do if you
have this choice uh well I'm a bit
confused can you even take on e4 doesn't
c6 still trap to Queen c6 interesting so
Bishop e4 and that's what happened so
Bishop takes c4 c6 b takes c6 is this is
a Queen sacrifice after Queen takes c6
indirect - yes it is Wow very
interesting game yes well we'll
definitely have to keep an eye on this
one but for the moment we do have Rhea
Robson here ready to come into the
studio so I'll let you take it away with
some more analysis while we get him
switched out so probably in this
position why it is not in danger of
losing but on the other hand on the
other hand White has easy play and
potentially could have some pressure on
the g7 pawn is Hamilton in danger I
wouldn't say so it's just interesting
play for Istanbul yeah Jack's tumble
yeah and I think he has good chances of
even putting some pressure but right now
not yet yeah so so I think potentially
this Bishop wants to land on d5 and the
hard part for Amman is to come up with a
plan with one minute on the clock
and I feel that this pressure can be
really uncomfortable in a real live game
even if the computer would say that this
is just fine for black I'm not sure I
would take black here but I don't know I
have to reconsider yeah so I feel that
there's big compensation here for
Shambhu lyac but is it more than a
compensation I'm not sure but I have be
Robson here who might have a different
view on this position what do you think
about this game yeah I only saw that
position for a few seconds but no I like
White's position to bishops look really
strong hmm the Rope can one rope maybe
can go to the B file other one they
could double on the beef ah maybe also
double on D file or 1 and D 1 and D and
I mean there's no way for black to force
off one of the bishops mm-hmm the only
way you could try to exchange it with
the 9 let's say 96 but the bishop can
just run away anywhere on the diagonal
so why just gonna have one Bishop on d5
probably other one on d4 or somewhere
else in the diagonal mm-hmm
they're very strong and yeah I think
practically definitely why it's better
and even objectively I think white has
some advantage mm-hmm so would you be
scared if black would go let's say 96 f4
and rar and trying to scare you rarrrr
yeah that makes sense
96 that's let's just put the bishop on
okay I said Bishop C 3 ok 1 4 yeah that
makes sense
good thing is the bishop on c6 is still
guarding f3 so we may not have to take
immediately maybe even like rook fe 1
good be a move because probably the key
files gonna open
aren't you a little scared of this f2
left undefended I'm a little scared
okay all right but you're gone I didn't
want to use the other rook okay hmm and
if I take an f4 then your knight gets a
very active square so the Rays point
here is if I'm correct that this rook
would get stuck here on f1 if I would
bring the Otherworld yeah so you'd
rather risk it
you know e1 mm-hmm and I mean Hamilton
has a minute and it's not that easy to
come up with some winner moves or very
strong moves in this kind of position
yeah I mean 96 f4 is logical but then
you still you still have to come up with
a good continuation and even if they
just even if what just maintains his
position again it's like there's kind of
no risk really mm-hmm
as long as f3 or something doesn't come
it's not really any real risk in black
has a weak d6 pawn potentially weak 85
pawn as well so there's uh yeah it's
just a lot harder to play with the black
I think yeah in fact Hambleton played
Queen c7 okay which I think I do think
that he needed to go and go for some
action some aggressive play maybe he's
trying to use some tactics Ola the Queen
on c7 there's ideas of moving the night
obviously and maybe maybe 93 and a
bishop d5 which looks logical then 93
and the night comes to before hitting
that Bishop mm-hmm and hitting 8 2 and
also depending where the rook goes could
be hitting the rook as well and as I
said white doesn't want to give up the
two bishops but let's say if rook c3 the
night before and the bishop can move
away but then the a to fawn is hanging
which could be an issue so possibly
white well if I was why I was I would be
considering just moving a bishop to a
different square mm-hmm I'm seeing if
that made sense yeah it does make a lot
of sense it doesn't make sense let's say
we should f3 or where did you want to
move the bishop right now the same set
of Bishop d5
okay let's you like this position so
Bishop Anthony was actually played okay
and now let's say 93 anyway mm-hmm c3 is
one move again and now if night before
then it's not hitting the bishop so
probably night before now you just have
a TV even here you still have a knight
c6 you're still gonna get one of the two
bishops mm-hmm
and again even if even what if white
plays Bishop takes Queen takes and puts
a rook on b1 I still don't think White
has any losing chances but at least
black got rid of the bishop pair mm-hmm
so what do you think in general when
would you accept you have a rook and
Bishop against the Queen is this the
kind of position you would be okay to
have the rook and Bishop if I have a
pawn it helps if I have okay more than
one confer it helps you even more yeah
this position because the bishop is very
stable on d4 and black has also played
f5 which is the good aggressive move but
in this case now it's opened the seventh
rank it's also kind of a weakness yes so
it's also harder to protect g7 actually
because you can never play f6 to block
the bishop so if white gets if I doubles
and puts a rack on b7 then you're gonna
have some issues with the g7 pawn oh
yeah here white basically has no pawn
weaknesses on the King side and black
Black's Queen doesn't have that much to
do mm-hmm it's not like it's wreaking
havoc taking always pawns so I mean this
is a good example I think of where the
rook and Bishop are probably better than
the green they kind of dominating the
black Queen because the black Queen
doesn't really have a target apart from
c4
it probably like may just play something
like h6 a gif in some space for his King
and then if if rook I don't know if it's
possible let's just say if rook could be
three in general roca cb3
mm-hmm maybe just like rook f7 just
guard the seventh rank and then then go
on from there mm-hmm and I mean it still
looks holding for black here yeah all
right so you drew your game I did you
had a fascinating c3 Sicilian
fascinating fascinating yeah all right
let's take a look at that just quickly I
don't think it's a big tragedy right
because it seems so you have a 30 move
rule right yeah I assume it's I think
it's for both sexes yes for both
sections yeah so like we could repeat
yes so did you expect bortnik to play c3
I don't think he expected me to play c5
oh okay because I used to play a
Sicilian every game but recently I've
been playing e5 every game and doing
pretty well so you probably expected
that again mm-hmm I wasn't sure if he's
gonna play for d4 mm-hmm when he plays
d4 usually plays like with Knight c3
Bishop f4 and he's also playing before
but he doesn't really played much at
least I don't know when I looked he
looked him up in the databases like he
hasn't played like a year or something
so yeah I can see fab normally he is
playing Knight f3
but then after Knight f3 d6 he was
usually playing just Bishop c4 this is
kind of a rare line again it's kind of
just play yeah oh so I was I mean I was
happy to just get a game and just play
but he played to c3 which I saw he had
played mm-hmm I didn't really look I
didn't really check because I figured
it's not really the most dangerous thing
so yeah I haven't played against c3 I
don't think for
two years two years maybe I played
against it in the world team 2017 it's
actually a funny sight I was playing
against you in the world open and I
actually thought about playing the see
thing and I said nod this is boring and
never bad boring for you
yes it's sooo boring for me well I used
to always play Knight f6 I think I also
have played d5 once or twice I even
looked at c3 recently and some sharper
ideas but I mean I hadn't really looked
it before the game so I just decided to
stick with the solid more solid line
interesting it's interesting I would
consider d5 more solid than nine f6 for
some reason I mean there yeah it could
be solid here too but I know not if six
better cuz that's not like group yeah I
mean that let me be honest here so let's
say if black considers playing Bishop f5
this is certainly not solid play by
black but like the e6 line as far as I
know is fairly solid yeah I played this
one one sighs and I said looked up I saw
here a few games here but again like I
just decided to stick to 96 and up stay
calm so he thought for a few minutes
before c3 but then after Knight f6 he
was playing quickly again 5 so it
probably this was still his preparation
takes takes yeah it's just normal theory
Bishop c4 B should be 5 and here I was
trying to say after Bishop c4 I was
thinking because I know you can take on
e5 ya see e5 and you move the knight
somewhere exchanging Queens and he's
supposed to be fine but again I didn't
it wasn't like 100% yeah
I mean I think 90 before is the move
Queen d8 98 and it should just be fine
for black but again Knight b6 is kind of
the old mainline that's the one I grew
up knowing how to play so again I just
stuck with that played Bishop e5 yeah
taketake yeah and this line which I
don't think I've
I'm trying to remember if I ever had
this position in an actual game maybe
once it's very interesting I mean I've
seen this position
lots of times because of the famous
Romanian Grandmaster I mean famous I
know mo played him and he's a famous c3
specialist like he has 90 or lots of
lots of games played in the C 3 lines
and he always played this position with
white in fact but if I recall
rook b8 is the move that they usually
play here and E 6 only then so Brooke
did what is why play because I was
thinking maybe I can just like castle
and mm-hmm
ignore the pawn rook d8 Castle yeah for
some reason and then they play a six I
guess oh I guess I know the point maybe
that I forced if you move the Queen I
can take so you forced to play Bishop
III but I played east six naked Castle
so okay but then you can still transpose
back yeah yeah maybe rook t8 is a good
move here but I'm saying I can still
play a six first yeah that's true let's
trauma oh maybe the idea was work to you
a six I don't know but yeah I think what
I believed was was I mean it was
obviously the most normal just
developing the bishop but I knew that
white has played Bishop e7 sort of a few
I know why it's getting like Queen g4
and stuff but and maybe has some
initiative yeah we have just the
breaking news that Petrosian did win his
game against fear and will be very
curious what he thought and what
happened because in that game it was
like hovering between equal
there's no opposed to colored bishop and
game i don't know if you saw the
Petrosian fee again not really no and
around move 28 to 33 was round equal but
it happened be afforded no around the
move 30 move fear was just shuffling
back and forth and suddenly made a
mistake near 30 so instead of an equal
opposed to coloured Bishop endgame
he was just lost you think psychology
has to do with that that you're waiting
for the thirtieth move to arise so you
can offer that also xxx movie once off
for a dry scene yes yeah I can I mean
you have to be careful so if you don't
mind I can pull it up sure so yep this
game so g5 so they were just shuffling
so fear just played rugby 7 mmm G takes
a takes rook at 4:00 and I've worked the
five kind of I don't know maybe so this
is move 31 already what you think he's
shuffling and just expecting he drove
because I can play this position forever
that should hold
yeah I guess but he has the he has the
outside passed pawn which is hard to
push for now but also I mean he's gonna
hit f6 at some point and he has efore
ideas and at lacquer plays f5 then I can
put a remember G file again he can play
afford some moment so I don't think he
would be expecting to just agree it
drawn a few moves i I kind of thought
that I really didn't see like what was
the point of playing rugby 7 and after
takes takes rook d5 I mean obviously he
missed this a for idea okay yeah but I
feel that there's some impulsiveness on
blacks part because if you're like just
defending the position and you feel that
you need to defend you would just go
back I'd suppose what I guess what it's
already threatening a for anyway right
yeah that's what I'm saying that I think
he just didn't obviously see it all he
just didn't see it you think and then a
for and after this technically is over
because I'm going to collect all the
pawns
and again but okay let's go back to your
game so here so II six castles so you
didn't did you consider room D though I
considered it up before but not with the
idea of playing east six cuz I thought
if I play six I'll just get the Bishop
to e7 okay but I was thinking about
trying to play g6 and I can't play g6
immediately because of d5 this reminds
me of Shanklin Caruana game where he put
Jesus then almost lost actually I meant
if I don't play a 600 kg 6 GC 5 D 5 and
that's nasty so I was thinking about
rook da o we say it'll be eight castles
and then g6
mm-hmm but I thought it's a bit slow
like rook e1 Bishop g7 Bishop g5 and
stuff is happening at 87 you know it
cross pins everywhere
Oh God that night and I knew East 6 was
kind of like a mainline it can't be that
bad so I decided to just stick with that
yeah so there should be seven was played
between g4 Castle and I think bortnik
played an inaccurate move Bishop takes
c6 is the line that's the the main line
I checked after the game yes but rook d1
is also a movie efficiency 6 and then
Bishop h6 coming is my guess I assume B
takes I mean I would have thought but I
was thinking about B takes mostly mm-hmm
and she made six Bishop f6 and white
play well it does it's not that like a
big advantage but it depends how either
how effective the attack is or at least
if I can provoke some serious weaknesses
because I have the d5 square available
for my night forever can't be challenged
and meanwhile do I badly just won his
game against Ilyas merit so in fact that
C pawn did prevail okay so so I have the
d5 square and the
airplane 85 mm-hmm 94 27 just if we ever
exchanged those an IV of that Bishop I'm
gonna have this night I mean I should be
able to hold most likely mm-hmm I have a
week c-pawn but otherwise my position is
very good so I mean this deep ones also
weak so it's kind of balancing each
other so it's still it's not a huge deal
rook d1 for some reason I was kind of
expecting route 51 mm-hmm
and then I played rookie th makes sense
I guess we'll get d8 so you have this
Bishop FAI yeah because both why
couldn't play Bishop h6 immediately
because the Queen takes d4 mm-hmm so
that that's why what takes the knight
mc6 because it takes in a defense at the
same time mm-hmm all right so Brooke d1
Luke d8 we should paid six here it was
interesting that he repeated Dan he said
no and yeah decided to simplify and here
I was thinking about h4 was interesting
actually I checked already
mm-hmm and no one's ever played h4
they've had this piece of you a few
times but the h4 is interesting it
should still be okay for black but
obviously the idea is to take back with
the H pawn if you ever take them the H
files no bin there were coming to d3 and
h3 looks a little bit scary and black
doesn't take then can you go King h8 or
something you could just kind of wait I
guess but why we'll continue with like
one maybe a look t3 I don't know okay so
h4 was interesting so the five happened
yeah but h4 is definitely interesting so
the five d5 wasn't bad but it's kind of
liquidating yeah it is but so this next
sequence is kind of force we get to this
end game with here's a Bishop verse
tonight mm-hmm and still yeah I put a
six to try to force off the bishop
because still pawns on both sides and so
his bishop is still better than my
knight so I played a six
he took which probably fine but after
taketake he had to play rookie tune and
I have weak pawns on the Queen side
obviously ANC and the idea of rook t2 is
just to stop rookie 2 and then he's just
gonna play a long game
just stop any counter play and we kind
of played by me bring his king to the
Queen side and just try to play I mean
he has he actually has some advantage
here this was the only real way to play
unless my row got to eat too I was but
you still have some good chances of
holding this I have a good chances but
this was like his only real chance and
after that it really was just
liquidating to add wrong after you put
your yeah my rooks just get way too
active too active even if he's up a pawn
and it's just wanna rock is gonna be
tied to like the F pawn so he's gonna
lose his other pawns eventually alright
assured but very interesting game what
are your expectations for this
tournament mmm I mean this is tough
tournament I like to do better than I
have done and these ones before I
haven't won any of them even if I don't
win like I'm trying to play a little bit
more combative maybe at least like in
this game I've been playing e5 as I said
or a lot recently and so I played c5
already in the first round so I'm
showing that I'm at least prepared to
just play open games if if that's what
my opponent also once and yeah I'm just
trying to do my best
I mean I think I played Darius tomorrow
huh and I'm white but we always have
really tough games I kind of expect a
big battle right there
maybe yeah it will be interesting
because we've I've also played him many
times I've been white so he he basically
knows everything that I've played yeah
as far as I know you've played
everything against him yeah I played
Cena or against him a few times I've
always played the e4 and Roy Lopez a few
times don't think he's played Sicilian
against me yet
but I think you'll have a fun town I'm
guessing your first move now I also have
a fun time guessing last time I okay one
of the last times I played c4 I think
and he might think you played f5 then I
played b3 yeah but in any case good luck
then and hope to see you back next time
as well I win yeah alright and after
this we're going for a short little
break and we'll be back
hi my name is Ryan Chester and I'm the
development manager for the Saint Louis
chess club I'm here to tell everyone
about a golden opportunity that we have
right now we're selling golden tickets
for $50 a piece it's a 50-50 raffle
$5,000 will go to the Scholastic chess
initiative for the st. Louis chess club
and $5,000 will go to a lucky winner
we're only selling 200 of these and
we've already sold many to grandmasters
and all of our commentary team as well
so if you're interested please call the
Chess Club or go to our website on the
homepage and buy a golden ticket there
thank you and good luck
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
hello we're back and we're here with the
winner of the day he beat Alexander fear
Petrosyan
good to have you um so how did this game
go for you because I thought that it was
a kind of even for a while and then it
suddenly turned mean we both know that
theory I think until until when when he
goes okay Bishop Jake to know I didn't
accept the c5 immediately but I think
some nice e6 then I see something like
this yes nice a castle a6 or Ruby hmm we
wanna get from yeah are you five
yes yeah so this was the old line but
somehow it's out of fashion right I
didn't like differ because it's Benoni
we saw a shop on g2 I think that here is
black is very easy easy play for black I
didn't like this G to be shopping no she
decided to open it up for this business
okay I can castle first
and I see 6d takes e5 and it's a main
line yeah yeah its main line or d5 here
or the are d5 here then Knight a5 and
what this is 92 a sequin baby 5 and it's
another victory so huge very big thing
then then I prefer to play these takes
e5 there is yes here also theory but not
so many games maybe let me guess the
number of games 20 games for Detex e5
roughly probably more from even more and
I think more because the more you talk
about it
or I feel that this is so rare yeah
take stage I think we should be sweet
yeah Mouse is kind of a finesse to
attack first and castle later yes
because the idea if black defense pawn
mm-hmm like not bt7
all night a 6 or 9 ft 7 ok all bad
ah ha it's everywhere because then black
is passive and can't okay rook the 1 or
long castle maybe I don't know yeah
that's the idea
and here 95 going Bishop c5 its threat
threat yeah I mean yeah even if you go
here I can't go terrible what also play
slowly tank black no idea but 96 he
knows this movement is so best move
yeah this is the typical King's Indian
you sacrifice the best way so take 60 to
97 and I notice also the shop is 396
look c1 it's but it's to play yes and
here if I Kobe 3 uh-huh then he a must
to consistory it's a good move takes
bishop d5 and now it's equal f3 ok ok c8
or probably a5 a4 the most ideas I think
is playable and should be equal maybe I
might be shop in g2 yeah it's that yes I
never gonna play a 4 or open it ok King
gave to Monday night before and before
and I just like the data yes everything
is an agenda change everything Bishop c6
like kind of to the English I know until
here but ok I know that it's equal but
what I can do
I can I prefer to take uh-huh
it takes be three and I think yes Bishop
sister is good move thank you should be
fine and here of course it's equal
position yeah I mean you do have the
freer play like you have some targets is
my idea generally to play somewhere if
or like Bishop c5 handy for but he plays
very fast
he plays a fight which is a good move
and it's immediately equalized and
Arthur King gave to a for its logical
move he moves Bishop c4 yes will be five
look III King f8 and actually I was kind
of curious dead at any moment like did
it occur to you that okay this is not
going to be a win did you consider
offering a draw or no not are in control
but I simply just the good moves I mean
G for a poor it's it's I think it's good
move okay okay so you realize that okay
it's equal equal I try to do something
like h4 and my idea was if he you know
wants to go if I've it might be played
g5 maybe yes maybe I guess some drug
trial yes then yeah and I mean you're
the only one who's playing for a win
here yeah there's some pressure yeah
okay seven rookies before was he really
playing very fast here at this moment
yeah CC I think one to me two minutes
I think it's okay just blunder yeah then
my idea and did you consider offering a
draw well he I mean that he stare at you
that okay this is equal to offer a drone
if for example change old rocks here
okay yeah no probably you just missed
this right yes so probably it has
nothing to do I think a seven is yes
yeah and after that okay seven and yeah
and I didn't see any idea what probably
sometime before now that now my rock is
coming ashore it's good stuff yes yeah
it's it's equal but you can still play
it but yeah so rogue d5 was played but
after eight for this trick I'm sure like
what's he shot when he saw yeah I think
it's immediately before yeah it's like
losing because I I get two points f6 and
g6 and and everything is falling yes I
have two connected which I'm curious how
did you come up with this move King e1i
I think about the hope she sees then
rookie seven probably I can play here
III but then he plays rook F seven and I
didn't want to push f4 yeah because then
this Bishop at least yeah they're also
very good yes I got more problems for
you technically I think King you want
more accurately but okay I kind of g6 is
also very good I think I thinking even
is kind of nice because you get rid of
any yes yes it's my idea to not give him
a counter here Bishop III rule g65
Bishop d2 was my plan was changed
another rooks and the bishop endgame I
think it's easy win
yeah cuz I put a bishop on c3 even he if
he pushed to c4 yeah just go response
because this H on in
in my bishop color and i think i didn't
see any chance for black so before was
played this is technically winning yes
bishop f7 and see for women to defend
his pawns but then i come slowly King F
to e for King g3 King therefore when
Bishop f6 and yeah he's basically just
watching you and he's King also very
passive I didn't see I don't think that
I immediately I want upon them that's
why I say O'Keefe exactly
I can play III King g3 nineties but I I
calculate that in the ironing yes I and
so why not take the pawn yes there
because if I take C five ponies okay
it's time to reason yeah so that's what
happened yes you just took all the pawns
yes soon here one working diamond just
one is promoting eventually and now
you'll exchange the rooks and this pawn
is cleaning yes so a very nice game I
mean there was some tension in the
middle game and it was kind of balance
it was not a clear game yeah I mean he
blundered a blunder very big move
mmm-hmm a foreign you have completely
lose losing position yeah but anyway I'm
just little bit lucky with I try part of
the game yes and I wanted to ask you we
all know that you're the second of Levon
Aronian
yeah it's fairly well known please and
wanted to ask does that give you
confidence in this tournament that yes
you have someone such a legend to
Worsley of course of course it's helps
to work with LaVon
to help him even it's I I get many many
things from him I learn I think it's
very good for me and I can try for that
door from leaven in my games actually I
kind of felt that this Bishop III move
was already a finesse and something that
very Levin ask okay I'm not doing
exactly what you're used to
it's something that you've seen a
hundred times before but not thousand
times so like very specific some sorry
Kiki opening I try to play something I
mean something some move which varies
not so big theory but I'm not lucky he
knows the best way equal one in the tree
yes and I think okay if draw draw what I
can do you know yeah so anyways what I
write to surprise but it's not working
yeah so anyways what do you expect in
this tournament to play some good games
and I'm a little bit tired because I
play two more tournaments before my
visit in USA when I help but now I think
it's a very good tournament
it's round-robin and all my opponents
are grandmasters and I can play very
interesting game
all right so thank you for joining us
and hope all the best for the next game
Thank You Eve yep
so we have four games left and I'm going
to take a look at the imaan Hambleton
game that we left off and it seems that
Hamilton is in trouble as this King is
cornered rook e8 is like a big threat
and if Czech manages to get both the
rook and the bishop coordinated somehow
just to attack that g8 square then some
black will be winning on the other hand
at the moment Amman still has a firm
control over g8 square so there is no
immediate win for Jack oh very
interesting position big thank you to
Manuel and right for giving those very
interesting interviews that's a huge win
for Manuel yeah coming out of this this
first round so it'll be interesting to
see how he follows that up tomorrow yes
so what's your opinion here you were
saying it looks interesting but can
white win this exactly
I have a feeling that eventually I might
need to start rolling this pawn but that
will entail some danger for his own king
as well exactly
the Queen Knight combination or this
Green Knight combination can become
deadly on the other hand that's not
really going to happen because this
Knight has to guard this g8 square
forever exactly it's going to get me
checkmate so I would assume that
Stamboul iakh is probably going to win
this game because black is totally tied
up right it's very hard to move yeah
that that's a fair point but so what's
your winning method how are you actually
going to break through here for example
it with black maybe I will just play
I will play this move Queen g8 that you
suggest in g8 mm-hmm
so it does me I could bring my Bishop to
b2 as well yeah absolutely
[Music]
maybe I can start let's take a look if I
start pushing because if I can just push
it all up there should be an easy win I
see your point
but now I wanted to play something like
Queen c8 for example you can see 8 hmm
she's trying to I'd these light squares
this diagonal in front of you probably
that's kind of helping me because I can
go rook c5 and a Bishop f5 maybe on the
other hand the fook see if I maybe
create and that hits my bishop and the
pawn yeah I just want to find some way
to get to this diagonal b7 is really the
square that I'm aiming for at the moment
so maybe I should go ruk a7 and just
take that if it seems totally fine but
now I wanted to play this move Queen c6
this was my idea and not okie 7 so I'm
just giving you a notice that I'm gonna
go to e8 okay probably get my Bishop
here now I think I have to pass I'll
play King G a king g8 okay so I think
it's time for this Bishop to go to be -
okay maybe I can play King f8 here King
f8 hmm
this this is starting to grow on me
because you can't even take with the
Queen because we kept sevens but I why
would I want to exchange off my bishop
pair yeah I fully understand but look of
seven what do you do instead just King
King g8 okay I'm happy to sit here here
you happy to sit oh maybe I can go here
yes and I hear that we're going to have
a seat for the interview absolutely
really quickly here yeah
can I take on e4 is that a too much is
dropping King f8 oh hi I wanted to keep
going yeah I don't know definitely an
interesting position yeah but I do want
to get the sea fin here well we still
have a chance for him yeah so once again
I will step out and we will let him get
switched in while you continue to to
look at some interesting games yep so
are you going to have a seat shortly
and even though Stan Bullock is
dominating it looks more complicated to
win it then I first thought I think this
game where Wasif won
it's very interesting especially in the
opening there were some moves by white
that kind of surprised me if you're a
grünfeld player you might not be that
surprised but if you're new to the green
felt some of the moves by receive might
surprise you and so just a quick rundown
so it's interesting that smearin went c5
here I kind of expected d5 to happen
probably smearin too and knowing the
Israeli player I'm sure he was ready to
play some double-edged positions and as
actually when L Petrossian said earlier
that when White has a bishop on g2 it's
not that bad for black to play a Benoni
structure so here we have receive
violations on your win thank you very
much can you get us through your game
sure what happening yeah saw sting
opening choice oh thank you I wasn't
expecting him to play this line but
luckily like a week before the
tournament I met with the Azerbaijani
player who's my friend I don't want to
go near him he's playing in World Cup
maybe he would use this variation I
guess is offered and or something so
actually he showed me this idea I go go
yeah here not see this before idea yes
which yeah I've seen basically what's
interesting in this position this is a
reverse grünfeld yeah kind
and they usually go this way so yeah
people used to play something like I
don't know be shot before 92 slowly but
I don't remember the who played with
white but before was played against Du
Bois I mean white was another Russian
Grand Master I forgot his name so he
played before and after Knight takes
before next takes d4 Castle Bishop III
94 93 93 F takes III a' and this is very
interesting position
I mean objectively it should be somehow
equal but I prefer white so I was aiming
for this position but what's smearin
played Bishop b4 was he surprised but
before I think he did not expect the
move and maybe he didn't know at all
haha
III did not ask him though uh-huh did he
think a lot he thought at least eight
minutes before taking bishop takes
before so Bishop before night before the
principal line I was thinking would be
Knight takes d4 Quinta Queen a4 now
Bishop d7 Queen before night C to Quincy
three night a one and hear something
like roughly one we shall be six and
Bishop 8 3 so but I couldn't remember
the my preparation so III mean I did not
check so I was going to think during the
game how to continue but I think White
has enough composition this King is kind
of stuck here
yeah but Samira told me he didn't go
this formation because of not Queen C 3
but Queen takes b7 huh Queen b7 rook b8
Queen a7 Castle be sure before
and here black a low-tech a1 because of
Quimby Eric Cohen beard we shall be head
and at then there is a move Knight a
tree and because of this mighty Bishop
can't restore okay eight and this Knight
is trapped and if you go there I thank
you and why it has advantage but I think
there is instead of Knight takes a one
black could play rook c8 and it's like
black is ok maybe even better
yes slightly yeah it's interesting that
sometimes because of these misplaced
pieces black has good play even if
there's two pieces for the rook yeah
about the day the main line would have
been this exchange sacrifice at the
Queen c31 Quincy tree yeah so it would
have been interesting game played maybe
the game was interested yeah so he
played Bishop before 94 Castle 9066 and
if you didn't take Queen BD 1 if I like
to be Texas then I think I had an
interesting opportunity to play Queen a
for aha go Queen be sick mb6
maybe I can play something like Bishop
III huh like Bishop c5 take take Queen
c6 and so how did you consider did you
consider disposition defendable for a
smearin or we saw that this is just
waiting for white after Queen a4 or
let's say this kind of positions where
you're up upon I was thinking that I
have good chance to win but you know
obviously it is not easy okay
all right so okay let's go back to the
game intakes here and let's take a look
at the last critical moments I think
instead of visual base tree maybe me
shall be six missions
and better better option so I was
thinking to play something like we shall
be five huh and I'm Shane takes a 393
and and I kind of still feel that your
pieces are a little passive and maybe he
has some hope yeah I definitely uh-huh
yeah okay so this was the game let's
fast forward so I think h5 would have
been a dumb mistake a mistake I don't
know
so here and I think Bishop f3 was the
big move I was considering Bishop g2 but
Bishop g2 after take and rook a4 yeah
Black is fine yeah this is just fine but
after Bishop f3 you just start rolling
them yeah hard to stop it I didn't know
how you needed to play here and after
this basically it's over this no it's
lost so it's a nice nice first round win
that was a good start
yes what are you playing next I think
I'm playing against a Cobian Cobian ok
all right so good luck for that round
thank you
keep going
let's take a look at the game's fun for
us drew that spirits this was kind of
this topical semi to rush that happened
fairly you know ship d3 knight c6 Bishop
c2 it's important to know that you can't
castle yet because ninety four happens
and there's no Bishop takes h7 tricks
you always have to play e5 so this
Bishop eight seven trick works so if you
want to trick your buddy and blitz this
is a fine little trick at the yeah the
classic the classic discoveries
discoveries are attacking it in the
DeForest yes so Bishop c2 obviously was
played between a5 and Suites could go
for b6 Bishop d7 which would lead to
complicated middle games but instead he
went for this endgame very slightly
worse because it has this extra pawn but
in the center but it's not a big deal so
Bishop d3 b6 King D to King King III
this is slightly better because Y can
potentially try to gain space yeah use
that central advantage to attack on the
game tonight c6 was played a3 broke d8
broke seeds fee and too many exchanges
happened here
and even though g4 did happen there's
not enough pieces left to win the game
right 96 and so this side just
eventually fizzles out and it just
fizzles out of the draw so an
interesting draw there yeah an
interesting so why don't we take a quick
look around the tables and see where we
are actually standing and at the end of
our broadcast today and over in the a
group let's let's check out what we have
so of course Rey Robson drew his game
yes against Alexander bortnik on the
first board and then what else has has
happened here
Thanks so this was a c3 sizzling a
quick-draw no let's take a look at dem
alchemy on any part of game sure there
Malcolm Young has a winning position it
was a very interesting game in the
beginning white sacrificed in exchange
and after complication it turned out to
be in Malcolm Yuans favor a pot of
sacrifice the exchange yeah
but eventually Malcolm young got into
this position and this should be
objectively winning Wow very interesting
well why don't we take a quick break
here and have another word from Ryan
Chester with an exciting offer on the
Golden Tickets hi my name is Ryan
Chester and I'm the development manager
for the Saint Louis chess club I'm here
to tell everyone about a golden
opportunity that we have right now we're
selling golden tickets for $50 a piece
it's a 50-50 raffle $5,000 will go to
the Scholastic chess initiative for the
st. Louis chess club and $5,000 will go
to a lucky winner we're only selling 200
of these and we've already sold many to
grandmasters and all of our commentary
team as well so if you're interested
please call the Chess Club or go to our
website on the homepage and buy a golden
ticket there thank you and good luck
very exciting stuff from Ryan Chester I
know I know you're going to be
purchasing a golden ticket oh yes we
shall see
well that's just about wraps up our show
for today so why don't we take a look at
the standings after round 1 and over in
the a group olexander Bortnick drew his
game against array that was that very
interesting c3 Sicilian that we heard
from Ray about alexei batalov is still
playing in front malcolm Ian but of
course he's probably going to win that
rook against Bishop X so we're expecting
a win from alchemy in there Alexander
Linderman did draw his game against vara
Cobian Jordan van forest drew his game
against Aris roots which we took a quick
look at and then lastly the seif who we
just heard from did manage to defeat
Ilyas Mirren using that strong C pawn
yes always use your strong
see pawns all right and in the B group
we have a veteran gorian who is still
playing against Steven xeric a lot of
games still up in the air here a circus
out of Perez playing against Dennis Cade
Rick actually Stevens are just won his
game wow that's a huge result for Steven
lots of results yeah it'll be a lot of
decisive games and Jackson Billy ik
still trying to win that position
against him on Hamilton of course where
he is actually down a rook and Bishop
for the Queen
but of course with so much active piece
play and play against the the black King
it's looking quite nice for him yes and
then lastly ronpa Cobian did win against
victor mihailovski and been well
petrosyan who we heard from won his game
against alexander fear and that of mainz
it's looking to be a very interesting
tournament already from round one so
many decisive results no real clear
leaders yet because so many players are
winning their games and as we heard from
both Manila Petrosian and Bay Robson
they're ready for a combative chess so
the e group is also ready for more
combative chess yeah and if you guys are
still interested in following these
games you can definitely still follow
along at us chess champs calm that's
where the games are being broadcast and
you can check them out for yourselves
there but with that in mind that's all
from me and Dennis here today be sure to
join us again tomorrow
starting at 3:30 for round 2 coverage of
the 2019 ball chess classic be there
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you